la parole est au président Roger caroci
pour le groupe les républicains
madame la ministre la France dispose
d'une autorité de régulation des médias
arcoms
sur son site
affirme qu'elle travaille naturellement
avec le Parlement puisque le Parlement
désigne 6 de ces 9 membres mais qu'elle
est totalement indépendante du
gouvernement alors madame la ministre
j'aimerais devant la représentation
nationale que vous nous rappeliez votre
définition personnelle de l'expression
totalement indépendante du gouvernement
pour vous répondre la parole ta madame
la ministre de la Culture
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur Elvis
Président carochi vous êtes un grand
spécialiste de l'audiovisuel nous avons
eu plusieurs réunions à ce sujet
et je pense aussi vous reprenez toutes
mes interviews toutes mes déclarations
publiques depuis mai dernier où j'ai été
nommé ministre vous pourrez voir qu'à
aucun moment
à aucun moment je n'ai commenté une
décision de l'arcom à aucun moment je
n'ai fait d'appréciation sur le travail
de l'arcome autorité bien évidemment
strictement absolument indépendante je
me borne à rappeler le cadre de la loi
les obligations les droits et les
devoirs que la loi de 86 prévoit pour
les chaînes qui ont des fréquences
gratuites les chaînes de la TNT je ne
fais rien d'autre que rappeler le cadre
de la loi est-ce qu'une ministre n'a pas
le droit de rappeler la loi
est-ce qu'une ministre n'a pas le droit
de faire état de décision qui sont
publiques de l'art comme j'en fais juste
état je ne les commente pas j'en fais
état je n'ai pas le droit qu'est-ce qui
vous choque et qu'est-ce qui fait peur
où sont les menaces est-ce que si
rappeler le cadre de la loi fait peur
j'ai envie de poser la question à ceux
qui se sentent menacés qu'est-ce qui
vous fait peur merci
[Applaudissements]
monsieur monsieur le président carochi
je vous rassure
reste ton calme je vous rassure madame
la ministre pas grand chose qui me fait
peur mais je ne bois je ne vous reproche
absolument pas de faire des constats ou
des commentaires sur les chaînes c'est
parfaitement votre droit comme c'est le
mien
et j'en fais peu
dommage mais en revanche quand vous
dites madame la ministre
éventuellement je dis pas que vous
affirmez en 2025
l'art comme pourrait retirer
l'agrément non je suis désolé de vous
dire retirez quand vous dites que
l'arcome pourrait retirer si cela
continue l'agrément aux chaînes en
question vous interférez avec les
décisions de l'arcom
vous n'avez pas je suis désolé madame la
ministre vous pouvez commenter autant
que vous voulez tout ce que vous voulez
vous n'avez pas à dire ce que l'art
comme pourrait faire en 2025 parce qu'à
partir de là c'est interférer sur
l'indépendance de l'arcom
et moi Madame les ministres je serai
beaucoup plus intéressé par vous
entendre sur cette fameuse réforme de
l'audiovisuel public que nous attendons
depuis cinq ans je serai beaucoup plus
intéressé de vous entendre sur la
manière dont on va financer
l'audiovisuel public puisque depuis que
vous avez supprimé la redevance
audiovisuelle nous sommes dans le
non-dit et l'intérimaire alors madame la
ministre remplissez pleinement vos
fonctions personne ne vous en empêche et
laissez-la comme faire son travail
la parole